welcome back to cbs mornings we are very
excited about our next guest actor terry
crews he's got a new memoir out today
called tough my journey to true power it
includes personal stories from his life
and his quest to overturn stereotypes
about what it means to be a man talks
about toxic masculinity we're going to
get into that you may know cruz from his
decades-long career including roles and
everybody hates chris brooklyn 99 and
the cult classic movie white chicks and
of course before that he played in the
nfl and he's also a businessman what
can't this guy do he's got a lot going
on terry crews joins us here now first
on cbs mornings you know when we go
through that list terry
your life has been so impressive in so
many ways that you were able to come out
of an abusive household that you had
these anger issues you played in the nfl
you decide i don't really like playing
football i'm going to go to hollywood
you become the successful actor but you
said that on the inside you weren't
really feeling
all the success that you were showing
people on the outside what was the
catalyst to really change that uh my
wife leaving me um
when uh
you know back in about 2010 what you
have to understand i was very very
successful
and
that can be the warmest place to hide
all your issues all your stuff you hide
behind the success because no one is
going to tell you the truth they're
always going to tell you that you're
awesome you're great you're wonderful
but i had all these things that were
wrong with me i had this rage that i
could not stop i could not control i
mean when i say not control it was one
of those things where any little slight
any little thing uh i would go oh yeah i
could there was a long line of people
that i had knocked out yeah and my wife
was like physically knocked out
in the face slightest little thing yeah
and you're like and people were like
what you know he's such a nice guy i
can't rectify what this is but i lived
my life like i was in a revenge movie
you know what i mean and i was going to
get back anybody yeah you ever did
anything wrong to me and it gets you a
long way it's a good motivator yeah for
a lot of men but the problem is
you're left with in your shambles what
works in the nfl is road rage in the
real world yeah right and it it did not
work for me and you opened the book with
a with a turning point moment where you
have an incident with a guy on the
street you end up i think picking him up
slamming him on the ground lambing him
on his head on the concrete
why was that the moment where you where
you said no more and you made a change
well first of all that
for me i thought i felt like i was doing
my
what i was supposed to do as a man
and my wife pulled me to the side and
said no
stop she said never you can never do
this she's at the minimum we're gonna
get sued and at the maximum because you
have to understand when i did this the
police came yeah they had their hands on
their guns you almost got arrested and
they were about to shoot me not much
more than an arrest and she's like look
you could get killed yeah she's like you
have to promise me that you will never
ever react with violence again and i i
did to kind of stop you know to kind of
calm the situation down
but she just had enough i know too much
let's say kudos to rebecca at this point
you you two have been together a very
long time because you you call it d-day
in your marriage where you went to her
and you said i've been an infidelity and
a porn addiction yes and porn addiction
for a lot of people terry is still hard
to understand for some people they
believe it's just a pass for a guy who
wants to screw around
what do you say about that oh well first
of all you know you were very candid and
very raw in this i i do it was a problem
for me because you know people always
talk about porn and they say well you
know if you're 18 and over it's great
but i don't know one person who's
discovered porn at 18. i was 9 years old
and i didn't know what i was looking at
i didn't understand i had never had a
conversation about sex with my parents
and i was looking at porn i had access
to porn and it was changing me it
changed the way i saw people i saw
women as objects and people to be used
rather than to be loved and it really
affected everything i felt just because
i was a man i was more valuable than all
the women in my life and it and all
these feelings and these things really
just permeated my life so i would it
allowed me to not listen to reason for
my wife to reason from the women in my
life and it caused me to really just
risk everything but you said nobody ever
really showed you how to be a man and if
a man is left to the fill in the blanks
of how to become a man that's never
going to work well when i was a kid
me and i was trying to find out what
being a man was all about it was so hard
because no one would tell me i would go
to an older man and i would say what is
this all about and they're like well
you're gonna find out yeah and i was
like man i'm 12 years old like can you
please tell me something so i made a
pact with my best friend i said if i
find out something before you do i will
tell you
and if you find out something before i
know it tell me yeah we're we're
parenting ourselves like the blind
leading the blind though
and that's the thing and if you're
taking all of your guidance on how to be
a man from the society around you you're
going to get the message that being a
man means taking it being tough yes
vengeance when it's required uh and
you've made a turn away from all those
things uh how did you do that first of
all therapy uh now you have to
understand another thing say that again
therapy yeah well you guys all say
together in my community
uh i have to say it it was one of those
things where they the term was you can't
cure crazy yeah and therapy was was
goofed up it was crazy they're gonna
make you crazy they're going to miss so
i had this conception of therapy as
being quackery and so
right and or weak or any you had to show
your vulnerability in therapy and i
couldn't do it couldn't do it and when
my wife left me and it was so wild
because i had a the best advice i ever
got was from a friend he said hey man i
can't promise you you're going to get
your wife and family back but you have
to get better for you and i was like
what and i went into therapy and i
started to to dissect everything about
me and i this is the thing i want to get
the message
that this book is going to send is that
you are assembly required
this is the way you come it's not that
oh man i'm just me and i can be all
right no no no you have to piece your
life together the way you want it
because just the thing if you don't do
it other people are going to be
assembling you yeah you know what i like
to in the book you say it's not about
getting for forgiveness it's about
making amends a lot of people miss a
part about the men's part that's right
you know
we're in a culture now where it's my bad
i'm sorry i'm sorry you can't hit
someone with your car and just be like
my bad i'm sorry and this is what i did
to my wife this is what i did to my
family
and when you damage them the way i
damage them you have to stand by there
you have to wait for the police to show
up you have to wait for the ambulance to
show up you've got to put you got to put
them in the ambulance you've got to take
care of them and let me tell you the
therapy and the years and the work that
went into this i had to re i mean
totally destroy the marriage as it was
and rebuild it brick by brick and we did
it we did it is terry crews all all good
today because listen we see you on tv
you seem to be this smile
mega smile yeah can i tell you i used to
be is this for real terry
well first of all what's so refreshing
because i go there in this book i really
do put everything out there but this is
the thing
i had external success that never
matched my internal success
and i was two people
now the internal has met with the
external and now i'm one person and this
is the the world knows way more about me
than i know about them yeah but that's
refreshing to me actually it's to really
let people know that they're not alone
and that they're they don't have to go
it's like terry crews was not born rich
and born of the star and all this stuff
it's work but it's that vulnerability
that really helps people see that in
themselves too and i love you keep a
picture of your little six-year-old self
on your desk that's for forgiveness
because this is the thing you keep that
picture oh there he is i used to think i
was bad i used to think you're a bad
person you're this no is that kid bad no
and let me tell you at no time in my
life that i stopped being that little
boy
terry it's really good it is and
probably the name tough my journey to
true power really
thank you because being tough is you
know
showing vulnerability is a form of being
it is well that's he says it really
hurts to grow you have to be tough
that's right gotta grow i had the
definition all wrong yeah i had the
ability to throw punches was tough now
the ability to take again yeah yeah yeah
really endure that's the true definition
of toughness great lessons you could
tell take this lesson to some other
people too
i have a list
we'll talk afterwards yes i have a list
terry crews thank you so much tough goes
on sale today wherever you like to buy
your books